our rights check one two
check check check I chose this game a little
bit loud but
it's good how about that then okay yes kid
sound
if you're there nobody's here yet but when
they come
do this once I have to turn it down once in
awhile
all right I do like the music in the
wintertime that's one of the reasons I
played cell
that's what we going to do continue
where in the bloody barons house
I'm going to go when you go to the Bloody
Baron and like walk around something is
going on with
him
so sorry we know Siri made it to the here
then we're going to we did that whole Quest
us and then we're going to go check out
where the bearings going to see where it
where Siri stayed and when I try to solve a
bunch of mystery sir so
that's what's up see if you can find him as
so pretty here
beautiful dream come true if it has problems
and I'll let me know that we're going over
here
is it busy
tomorrow's rooms are
no I don't have any vodka
I need to get my my stuff fixed drive me
crazy all right so we going to do our winter
stuff in here and figure out what's going on
thing I can buy the winter so much is it it
really is a mystery and there's like all
this Mister stuff you can play as well
so I'm going to Catskill song
this is something to examine
stem is broken okay
something here for me to still probably who
got gold studs can be worth money
what I can ask me this how can I argue that
there's nothing too ugly
what is this
I just sent there to igni know all right
this one again what's that about
fresh flowers huh
so they tried to come back
this is tomorrow's room so this is the room
of his wife
so like what's going on here so that I don't
think the bear is still in this the whole
story something is going on
nothing in there
what's this anything here holding up what's
okay sorry about that is my
is my powers
we're going to steal them blind because they
don't care if I said I was rude
there is a picture of the Bloody Baron and
his beloved tomorrow wife
and some really awesome flask you know what
I really really loved reading the 3D
craftsmanship in this game I can sit here
and watch it all day just cuz of that I'm a
very slow with your player in case you
haven't wondered so
a painting was there
I wonder if we can I wonder if we can hack
me this nope
so that's not it
Candlestick was broke why would the
Candlestick be broke
the Candlestick Barbie broke the Candlestick
broke because somebody hit somebody with it
that's what I think
without cooking sets good there's a red
thing we missed
wait that's a painting what we didn't look
at it
oh wait it's what I just said
there's a hole in the bucket dear Liza dear
Liza there's a hole in the wall hole dear
Liza hole
it says I can do something there but I don't
think I can is it on the other side oh hey
look
oh just give me a dead person in their it's
dead person
it's sir is no coincidence could you have
Gerald
Carol you're a smart dude I think you're
smart something happen somebody got hit
and stuffed in the closet is there blood
is there but why is there no blood because
it was a blunt instrument for didn't cause
any but what there's more stuff what the
hell okay
we already saw that girl we saw the flowers
I didn't say look at the flowers I said look
at this just listen to Gerald you're not
listening to me okay
deep Nick's hit with a heavy object like
somebody's hands or something
there was definitely a scuffle there was a
kerfuffle there was a scuffle up we have
more information
more information is this Blood I'm telling
his blood right when I was about there
before
are you sure evolus
it's called evolution
oh oh I love it when that happens I love it
when is winter sister show you like the air
Trail and that fun
this game is so awesome I love this game
this game game rocks
it's so pretty I wonder if they can see the
sense in the air
why don't you stick it up your fat ass all
right
I'm tempted to go down there but there's
like too much red stuff here
walking down walking down it's so pretty
walking down walking down
no it doesn't care
yeah I'm saying right there go look at that
talisman
yes please take off
Juniper Juniper
you don't think what I think you might can
White's fun with her
I'm so sorry Barons card for your hangover
I'm so sorry all right we got
is it Garden here should I try to steal that
stuff under the garbage Jeremy
with a guard right there a Jeremy to steal
stuff did Emma do it
should you save scum
it's just an empty bottle all for an empty
bottle no I'm not feeling as Empty Bottle
Store in front of the guards just for that
hey Barron's has been let's talk what's up
dudes
all right
well as everything else in there I think
it's above us is like up filled up his image
is what it is it's one of those California
chesty things
what's that if a betta fish is pretty strong
yeah
that that that's because we have our senses
on and I've been living my senses on all day
if you maybe regular Key Food surge of
Senses of OSHA oh shit was this
this is what series did yes it is
great cuz toy track West yes
okay we're doing a bunch of questions same
time this is
this is good this is Brenda pretty in here
you stay here all day it's nice and warm
makes me warm and cozy I just want to go to
sleep and come go to sleep right now
I kind of need to go to sleep I don't go to
sleep though cuz I'm a Witcher
stash this is cool anything you put in the
stash you can pull out of the stash later
I don't have anything in the stash cuz I
just saw my shit
but if I wanted to I could I guess I wanted
to put my fancy pants fancy ass like clothes
in there I probably should do that but no
I'm going to inspect
so we found series room so we have
tomorrow's room at the mystery of tomorrow
going on and we also have series room which
is the main quest tomorrow's questions
tomorrow we're having it tomorrow is kind of
a
, Cypress Bayou the natural obscurity of
curses
let's read it
to my dear friends Phillip banana from Court
minister of culture of the kingdom of
tameria Zima 1265
whoever thinks curses are only are only a
manifestation of one's being ill will
towards another his solar sorely mistaken
shockingly, play some reports a cast on it
wouldn't lie on oneself on object in one's
immediate environment the cause of doing so
can be difficult to predict
in many cases that lead to harm or even
death of the person think about the curse or
other people spending time with the object
or being on which the first fell that is why
it is so essential to take preventative
measures to safeguard oneself as soon as
possible against the casting of curses as an
absolute minimum
Amelia Amelia Veracruz Leon recommends
cleansing oneself of all negative thoughts
striving to be at one with the world and
achieving Harmony baton between body and
mind what is she
well so there's something going on about
curses here
and they wouldn't tell us about curses
unless somebody was cursed
so I think somebody is cursed
somebody related to series Quest is cursed
we don't know who it's not Siri might be
Siri could be tomorrow
some be related to Siri to sirius is course
they wouldn't give you a hint if it weren't
that
I got them with the lights on because it
just makes me happy enough that we had, nice
room there was this one over here to the
other Quest though
oh God oh God what is this dead animals
everywhere
you ain't lying to make the guts Sparkle
is it there like Fresh Cuts around nice and
wet and everything so gross it's so gross
probably realistic very gross it probably be
drier than that
I got fish I answer because I'm like looking
for shit Quicksilver I'm just going to steal
him drive
I do everything over here with the dead
animals
abrasive County's got a brace of conies
there what the fuck
hey Greg, how's it going I know you from the
thing I did with Siri
Edge or carrots
Siri tell me about you what else did Siri
say
friend in trouble I wonder if the friend
who's cursed
ha hundred XP wow I was fast
alright farewell
I'm not playing on my open
videos de still yeah a great can we were
pleased I got to steal this cotton right
here
is that like just guts on there it is it's
like a thing of guts
it's gross stuff is gross it's definitely
gross in places
God damn the witch which is so fucking gross
are you real or are we
we're already up here let's go back
go back upstairs where I can turn it off now
all right if you say so dudes oh wow
I feel like when I'm done with the other
question that though
cuz we on
one thing they're going to spend points for
something I don't know
using wine no this is I'm using proton in
Steam it just work straight up
I just had to turn proton and it works so
let's do a singing which is better no not
the show Family Matters
let's finish Family Matters talk to the guy
about what you found the kids so we got if
that's the only thing we have that's the
only thing that's good
if I do this one
and then I switched back to what we need to
do so she could talk to the beer and I had a
feeling we kind of left a question done so
let's go get him
hey you want to say that again to my face
my fucking attacking you piece of shit to
say stuff about my face
all right wait where's the baron then where
are you dude
must be upstairs
no I do not I'm at with you
all right here we go hey Baron what's up
dude
Anna
Anna was wary of strangers and you Converse
and his old wife
size of the fight in the room
you're lying
bulshit bulshit
you are telling us everything you piece of
shit and I'm going to steal your going card
later because it alright
I guess I'm going to go see the pillar
the pillars part of a another another to
Quest another huge
got any vodka is that the only thing you
ever ask
what's it what's in your anyting 08 we can
go in here
we did not anything fun in here. There's
lots of stuff
oh God that was that was a good clean kill
what
sound on wait something's going on here
something is going on
when is that say tomorrow it is tomorrow
letter to tomorrow we are more like a family
we support each other and each other's
survive Teflon its grapple with the pass for
each of us has a past
so you didn't worry about anyone digging
into yours we've got a rule never asked more
than someone offers on their own
that's just a hint of somebody's lying
the past doesn't matter to us only the
future does that as are coming fight against
evil into property is perseverance
his perseverance in loading this practice of
all kinds of somebody saying that they're
lying
that I'm telling you the baron is lying I'm
pretty sure he's lying
pretty sure he's lying that's a very nice
fire though I just want to sit here all day
let's follow the scent pretty another
you keep know I don't you keep asking me
that and I keep telling you
we just fell down the stairs Gerald girls
too enthralled with the scent is a senko
you know what kiss my ass alright so
going down here
I'm not stealing a broken rake
I don't want to fight these guys over a
fucking broke and Rec stuff in here maybe
though
can I see me oh shit
I can't see me they can't see me oh my God
silverware we scored on that one
silver or yeah oh shit this is great can I
see me know okay more stealing
lots of spirits the tour of spirits
sup is also going to sell will sell of that
will make my money wait why aren't you
why are you still untapped I'm at my skills
right
a bear hide asador and Spirits over here
money
El Potter's in water
kind of office sent but I wants
water is good water is nice locked I have a
key though
where's Mikey where's Mikey
I don't know where my key is I don't
you know what shut up what is that
I'm kind of broken thing
a Baron's guards what's up more stuff but
that's can I go in the store
oh God more stuff cuz pretty in here is
right by everybody going to get mad if I
steal anything
I'm still in blind I have no ethics I'm a
Witcher
I think it's funny that you cuz I still
everything in this game and did you ever get
any consequences unless you're like right in
front of the Guard
and they got to be able to figure out that I
took other stuff
okay I'm a little worried 222
Emerald dust shit Emerald us is good
you can craft all kinds of stuff like that I
think we're on the right track
the gala stuff guess not
all right when we got here
I just put a burning torch in my pocket hey
cyanide
this is pretty
I think my I think my thing in the bottom is
too big going to move it give me a sec
I think my name is such a big I'm going to
make it smaller my face you don't need to
see me this big
I think it's more that you guys have chat on
even make me turn chat off to me
and I got smaller like this really nothing
much to see here
2 2 2 2 2 2 2
so sure that I guess you could put I'm
trying to decide what I want to
adhere
everybody name of the casting of Henry
Cavill oh my God and then he can he left
yeah that's kind of a bad part about it she
left yeah he's not in the next season
hey look I can punch with my hands in Fists
yeah I want one more adjustment here
like this just a little bear had
it's cover up that shit that was in the
corner
back to the game I don't need to fight
examine
oh it is the Eternal fire Citronelle fire
that's like the mean
a prayer let's read it
Eternal fire which lieth our hearts and
giveth us light Henry Cavill left yeah
heat us
the second pill mutant he does with that
warm dry our tears burn our foes embrace our
enemies in like air give my mother Health
punish my father so the people who follow
the Eternal fame or are these kind of like
to sell it sort of Sue do you know
evengelical kind of things kind of results
support you know that
the somebody has definitely been worshipping
the wife I'm I have a feeling it's his wife
because I hope Ella is supposed to know
stuff I think that she got converted that's
him I think I'm going to guess I don't know
if that's it but
find a pillar site so we're going to be
traveling quite a bit quite a distance to do
this we have to go far far away I'm going to
be fighting a lot of stuff on the way so I
happen to know there's a blacksmith nearby I
need to go fix some stuff and do some
Trading
or we leave
I can try to get out of here when I don't
have to go to the main level aha
hair of the Hound I really don't
I just been sharpening sort of long time
wow it's a beautiful day take a nice breath
and breathe it in
I got this beautiful glorious morning
glorious morning
wow it's like right there so I know there's
a bunch of stuff I need to do here
what are these guys doing parents henchmen
they're not having a problem roaches over
there
where's all the resources and stuff I know
there's something over here somewhere
you really can't get in any other wake up
for you this is though lately this game this
is why this is a game of the year we had
this thing man that there's nothing like it
this is on low Graphics settings I swear
it's just so fucking beautiful
I could just sit here forever
it makes me so peaceful every time I play it
no it's just like you know just opened old
monsters place you know
I love these kind of Epic like Landscapes
this is so it's super immersive that's what
makes it so amazing
nothing to talk about there you can't steal
anything in front of the guards or the kill
you
I want to think that there's something else
here that I don't know where it is that's
what I was looking for
they're that Sherpas all your stuff right oh
I'm sorry hun
I'm sorry oh here is serious the dwarf
dorms is out I want some better shit
their fires may be released from prison
region cuz he's people of an Ice Age
apocalypse coming and it kind of do you
they do look for a master armor yeah
that'd be great actually
yes the skellige we're going to go to
skellige
the north side of the Isle of skellige we
have to remember that the north side I'll
Skelly we're not anywhere near it but we
need to go there so that we can have that
unrequited
it's like special armor you can't make it
any other way
all right. That I did not know about that
Quest
I did not know about that Quest I've latest
before that's it I'm totally Miss Equus if
for some reason this
I would like to play gwent what you got
okay I got a lot of random shit that I could
sell it's actually better to craft
actually better to craft things I got this
this round through which was my second time
I did it kind of speed did it last time this
round I've been doing I miss spending a lot
of time Slow Time on Crafting and shut and
it's been really fun and really loving it
so we'll see if we have anything we can even
craft right now the Gibson
is it how is it just a no-good
it's going Gibson armors no good at my armor
is better
this armor is going to get it I don't have
the stuff to
to make everything new give me trousers that
way we don't have any we have any recipes
actually
was that
it boots just don't know just when we have
any yeah he just has armor so he doesn't do
weapons that's fine we can just buy stuff I
need to repair shit though I need to get a
repair
going on I think I could probably sell all
that weight wet
crafting lesser glyph lesser glyph
bounty hunters Gibson 25% of his requires
level eight I'm not level eight yet again
dismantling items I don't want to just metal
items no I would rather not
if you want to recover some of your
professor made of space I didn't know you
could do that
I did not know that this is new I've never
dismantled anything before
okay cool I this is not something I have
done and they have to pay for it says Mela
interesting
well that's cool I remove upgrade
oh so you can actually replace it with a
different of great I didn't even know you
could do that I've never done that it gets
only we got to get a good guy to do this
sounds of shown here even said I could
actually change the Rune shit that's so
expensive
wow I did not know you do that
this is be fixed space repair equipped yes
please
good now and go fight monsters
I agree to go crafting remove afraid repair
smell tool shop to me anyting
do they have anything I want + 11 shit those
are way better than my boots
+ 3 I mean why not are they are they sexy
though
they must have a socket for him to 17
releases piercing damage at 11
none of coin we talkin about how much are
they
335 that's what I much how can I have it
it doesn't make any sense 17/15 hour
I want those I must have them is there an
app to sell something
potions stuff
you invited myself on how about some of this
amethyst stuff whenever I said that for him
it hardened leather that's a great Crossing
phone at 2 though
monster Town Crossing Apartment how much do
I need to get these boots
Pride level 6 I don't have a 6 okay fine I'm
at this
master item card level 5 all right
and of course I mean I want to go to 66
you know what I'm fine I am just fine I'll
need your fucking thing I know I'll play
Quentin win some money from you
yeah they're going to do I don't know how
good he is yet so I'll wager anything yet
anything yet serious
I don't know how good it is so
keep calm and keep my my deck as is play
some Grant
oh God please don't be good decoy is a great
thing turns to rain
to Commander Thorn if you don't need that
my surgeon hearing these guys just a really
well so so today
this guy's a really well let's do one of the
commanding horses kitchen one
I don't know how to do it is it Chickasaw
Center select
yeah okay mr. Archer we can use him
I mean I mean it's not that's not bad it's
not a bad deck Escape
start of the round please don't be good
who's playing is playing skellige Skechers
Go to title or whatever Scotia 10
I'll fuck I'm going to destroy this dude
destroy him he's not very good
I don't even know if I need this right now
so
I let's go let's go let's keep it rains cuz
he's not going to hurt range people
Denton tune
do you pull out a sixer but he's really
going for it all right
I'm making he passed he kidding me he passed
on that he passed on that
shit has play one of my who wins the tie I
think it was around 1 if there's a Time
to find out I don't remember if that's true
as all-in-one television syndrome
I don't know if where you at I'm at this guy
what does he do can you cancel what does he
do
doubles all the strengths of all the unique
cars in that row limit one per row
I don't need that
I mean she let him win this round that would
be funny
and now it's just too easy of a win is it to
easy win okay here we go
and he's not very good yeah I think we have
this one easy
if he's like really bad I'm going to like
rip him off creepy fly in the lot
so play I get to go first I came so
what do when do when do mr. lowly dwarf here
she likes the words so I should that should
work who God level 6 range
haha
I don't know about this I feel like he's
being sneaky
I got six cars left I'm going to destroy him
chance of rain is only for
Siege, yeah
what is the special ability it's a special
ability is
but it is impenetrable fog which takes down
taking a picture of off your card and put it
in sleep
I don't have it it's in my deck yeah so that
will take out the ranged let's go for it
let's go for it
there we go
I mean he'd burn in a lot of cards there God
look at him is burn a lot of cards
it's got to looking for cars left
all right I'll let him have this one I'll
let him have it I'm going to destroy them
next game
seriously you're going to burn that many
cards I so when this guy got three cards is
not going to wind no alright you when I'm in
the next one
yeah you want so what you have three cards
left the moron AI moron
ASU vs U 10 hey look he has two full cars
left at least you have something really
weird
Isis it happens here
oh shit as for that I used to have clear
whether I don't have that
search Hawaiian card love if it's
impenetrable fog we're kind of fucked
I seriously hope it's not impenetrable fog
if it's impenetrable fog weird fucked
if his last card is a fog his Patty passed
he lost he lost it's a Volkswagen tell you
wait I got to get over at 10 here I'm barely
going to beat him
I'm barely going to be there early shit that
was a close game
but let's let's knock him out in an in a
nice way
oh wait that can only be played but what
I can I can play that in a reply yeah there
you go how's that take that
unless I want to kill myself which I don't
there I want
Victory it's pretty close so it wasn't that
bad
but I just got 10 crowns
oh I got a new card nice
are you playing again let's play a game or
time now that I know you suck I'm going to
take all your money
zinc enter airplane in the rain to
okie dokie we have a new card so we need to
go figure out where it is
I think was a skeleton card though actually
I think it was I think a new one we got
Cal a shity card
lots of sweet we don't have enough for any
of these texts yet
oh God I have a I have a hero card wait what
did I get the hero card from
I don't have enough to play this so it's too
bad
schedule I think we just didn't
Northern Realms guard
what's the new card I just got out of this
guy
I mean it wasn't that big a deal it wasn't
that great of a card God damn it I need to
start winning some Heroes heroes are the
ones that kick ass this like this guy this
guy kicks ass man
that's a guaranteed can't touch him and he
can play that you can play with either place
that's going to be a good monster deck
eventually eventually
and the new here are there any and all these
are there any and all these it was this guy
Claire weather in that we don't do that
Circle Game
all right one last one I'll get some money
here I know you guys are bored with this is
really funny like a decoy I like it when
somebody is awesome
God damn it. I drew Alyssa same cards as
crazy
I mean he's kind of went so let's redo him
through him
all right that's better
do you have any Siege things at all I don't
have no I do have a seat thing okay great
that's going to have to kick ass then these
guys are going to add points everybody okay
so big time Siege
I thought I did replace it I did I can
replace it but I got to see Joe God
I'm going to destroy him this turn level 1
all right
I mean hey look I got to work mr. Scalia guy
what is this fact so, that's why I thought
happy weekend everybody how are you
Abigail I'm in this to win this about
Windows I win 20 gold which is a lot shit
what the fuck is that
do we want to keep going on with this battle
or not I guess we do
we're actually pretty well-matched
shit that's like do I want to let him win it
and burn up all those cards or not
or do I really kick his ass right now
that's the trick right
I don't know if I'm if I'm at horn yet hey
look he put two people on there so if I did
that let's do this
he'll lose Marlisa.
All right so that's going to take us down a
notch that should put me ahead yeah
and that that was a good you said that card,
my God she's sexy I'm doing pretty good
so when we got here
I think I'm winning actually it does he plan
on a car what the hell is Tuesday idiot
I'm going to gamble on this I'm going to get
in this game
I'm pretty sure I get the next two games
automatically
it cuz he is out of cars and I have I just
put back in really high playing cards for my
deck
why did they pass why did he pass
why did he pass that's interesting going to
pass to I'm going to give up on that game
depression test
play Chief Keef fast he literally passed out
I have to play as like one card
I mean
okay he already passed so I'm going to pass
now I'm going to win
I definitely won this he doesn't play every
fucking thing here
all right unless he has God damn I'm going
to blow him the fuck away if my Siege stuff
you got nothingI'm I hate to tell you but
you got nothing
imma let you pay all your fucking cards up
soon to blow you away unless you have
infinitive Austin there
and I frost the other one and unless he has
a weather card
if you have the weather card we are fucked
let me watch watch this I'm going to double
it all at the very end 24
not sure what you got dude show me how much
I owe shit he had to put a weather thank God
I was afraid he had the other whether card
that would have kicked my ass watch this
30 what you got you don't even a damn cars
to play dude
are you not going to play that last card
what the fuck
is there second game is Arthur game right
all right with feeling now 16 points vs your
yeah that's me winning in a dramatic fashion
I don't think they hit he has any clear
stuff 120 friends or not
alright one more one more because I want to
buy those boots I want to buy those boots
I want to kick your ass and Gwen a couple
more times so I can buy the boots I know you
guys don't like this I don't care
all right let's do he doesn't have three to
deck it out
okay biting Frost knocks out first levels
another Siege we got lots of first levels in
this deck
so I will not be playing biting Frost ever
so we can replace that
it shut you are seized dudes
oh my God we're going to kick out so it
doesn't have a spine this done this is fun
let's do it
I had a spy
weather in play something really good and
his spy the shit out of him
play Cervantes Battlefield counselor to
phone the solo and Draw 2 card from your
deck
as if I wasn't already going to win
you want to play Ultra is okay with the
archers
I think it's a good idea to keep on the same
room as him so it doesn't kill the weather
in the same row
that's just a tactic Kimberly I'm flaking
ranged
what the hell
oh my God
should you really want to win this one don't
you
well let's go frontline's Highway
can you really just going to town God damn
look at you go
let me see wasting cards you know what fine
you can have it
if you want it that bad it's fine the thing
the AI does not know how to do is when to
quit
it does not know when to quit it does not
it's stupid it doesn't know about the cards
to give him in until
if you want to only I that's why I that's
how you doing
got to actually get her
choose one card from your discard pile
played instantly
let's play
arranged are you
yeah you're you're done are really tall and
I'm sorry to tell you but you really don't
you're going to do this you're really going
to do this you're still going to lose I'm
still going to beat you I don't care
change my forever shining Never Dies
19 and they passed and I won
pom pom pom pom pom pom pom
so
I mean how much. The blitter ate this guy
I'm going to get over 60 on this
turn to rain fuck oh fuck
and all my stuff is Siege I'm still going to
win but it's not going to be as spectacular
please please have a rubber frog
it looks like it's a stormy day today he
said we could weather oh my God
surely have every Weatherguard on the play
on the table
oh my God it's so funny I'm going to win
with one point I'm going to win with one
point
but his heart is going to fight with you
have what is Lincoln play
I fight God damn stupid weather card I mean
I would have kicked his ass look at this
I mean I really would have kicked his as if
I hadn't had that
I still got 26 even though it's weathered
out if it wasn't weathered out
dick dick dick dick dick dick dick we win
20 more gold for me that you're in much can
I buy those boots yet I don't know if it's
worth it
Escape how much gold how much coin do I have
toss a coin to your Witcher new item
received sill plates
I gave me some shit because I won
I don't like rain it is I have to know about
me I don't play in the rain I hate it
I hate it sue me how do I meditate I
I want to sleep I forgot where sleeping is
meditation what is meditation e19 he went to
meditate
where to meditate until I get to the
nighttime
alcohol is used to make yourself better
refreshing lyrics Hey look it's it's night
time I don't mind going out in the nighttime
I just don't like the rain
that girls either way
girls Shanty is actually the only one you
got to got her head and replace I've never I
don't know Shawnee I don't know who that one
is
which one is she is she the first one
is she is first girlfriend I think she is
open meeting
which one girlfriend I don't remember I
didn't say which one sorry
don't know let's play gwent Everybody your
voice but I have a feeling I'm going to kick
his
honestly I'm going to kick his ass cuz
I know gwent is not what everybody likes but
I do like it so there a god is Northern
Realms 2
a decoy is always good Trisha rain
I don't know it depends on what else have my
deck
I got tons of CJ I can't do too much rain
turned to rain is bad on Siege
so I don't want that get that out yes you
can go away
Mister one point but he has all the points
to cards in his row so I can keep him
how can I get those seats all right let's do
this
the grocery money Italy is
all right I got to go first I guess all
right Miguel
I swear as I can't post this video to
YouTube because I have any sound
let's go big or go home maybe I'll actually
win the first round this time usually don't
really or at least use it now
God damn I don't have a clue whether I need
to get that I'm glad I didn't play anything
else this time
all right you can win this game I want my
big old card back
are putting past really fuck that then
you going to give up over that really I was
stupid
alright I'll win it and I'll get my big
thing back
promises made equanimity
please the woman with the nearly naked
breasts why they did I don't know
he has more cards me though he's playing
Siege too because he's Northern realms
yeah he ready he ready plate if he has two
of those we are kind of fucked but I might
not need this
I'm a card down from him shit he's Mister
seeds to
I'm not pulling on my secret actually
are we going to do this way to go see versus
Siege cuz he's northern northern sky lots of
huge stuffed shit
oh it's on dude it is on
this is scary 25 to 25 for cars lift
can I play my double right now this is an
expensive game
the only double Siege pieces so I have to
play at this game that might have cost me
the game right there
but I won the first round right so
God damn he's like going out for it
he's going to go the whole way he knows if
he loses this when he loses. So cuz they're
in the first one so
oh I was afraid of that I'm still ahead two
cards left
this is scary because I didn't I didn't test
about before
if he has another advantage of a weird till
they fucked if he's got another weather car
there
now he doesn't he lost he's cut dijkstra
oh shit please don't drown impenetrable fog
please don't fart
or whatever the other one is he didn't do it
I have to pass
come on come on baby I got nothing
you got nothing boom take take that 2 round
knockout
I got 20 crowns I get a card he's not good
enough to give me a court he did give me a
trench line I don't want to fucking to
refrigerate I don't need another weather
card
I was going to stuff you have to sell me
mister yes please
what are you offering
bunch of stuff a can of can't have you cuz
I'm too low circuito
oh my God he's got going cards he's got he's
got a hero card already have this item
and then it hears hears hears there's a rule
Always by every going card
I'll have to find some winter gear okay imma
buy that I'll buy that I'll buy that
what is this slightly better crossbow
for supper I don't do that was a nobody then
I don't need anything else
Mooresville I don't need that yet it's kind
of cool though I found it but yeah I just
played a ton of it
yeah I was just find a ton of it I'm just
made
I just made like 120 gold from Quentin
now I'm not that smart no I just been
playing cautiously
and there's one secret always buy all the
gwent cards you encounter no matter what
it's like kind of a secret because you don't
offer him later if you wait later they
stopped offering them
I love Quince I love it
Sony Max inventory that's tempting but
that's like really expensive I already spent
all my gold like that I just won so
I think we're done here sure will
I just got used to fighting huh so tomorrow
is lost we don't know where she is
I am in playing gwent so my shifts been like
fading so go sharpen everything up
transforming cars I want to watch Ryan train
that's probably true
and I probably wasted my money on that but I
did not are these are all fun but they never
the quest
die the sheriff was going to be buried her
in the graveyard by the cook of her children
wants to replace the love of Earth and can
look into that's where you go quietly or new
players that went blank Society across
purchased for new members
a pervert where is this
oh bloody Baron plays Quinn okay by Slug It
Out in the ring come see us this is a fun
one actually
SSI question was funding a punch punch our
way through things reward all right side
quest to encourage CERN
there's a Shrieker haven't heard we race
horses oh and there's a horse race
yeah that's pretty standard every every
place you go they have like a horse racing
contract for the Beast listen to that one
. That track Fist of Fury velen
no I can try calling Beast of Burden
I got a lot of side quests list of side
quests and I'll be done
I completed yeah I completed it but I did it
pretty quickly I completed it with Jennifer
line but I didn't do I skipped most of the
side quests in skellige cuz I was so into
the main quest I honestly I just did not
care
so this this is the opposite this is I'm
playing like every fucking thing in the
whole world I literally inspected every
single area in the other one was it
why don't you say so
all right, take his harness and play 10
cards per game that's hard to plan it or set
it is
show me what you got I don't have any money
I got nine gold but I still want to see what
you have what is this
common item we got going cards circadian
fire scorpion
20 shit I need to get these
are you going to build up your other decks I
think that's the transfer has probably
wasted right but I have to play him some
going because I have to buy those cards
what is how I don't have any money I'd like
no you do it
take a look
are they going to another invisible fog I
did
and I guess I'll game I'm going to be guess
I can kick this guy's ass right after I get
out of the bed
decoy is in the house Siege experts again
I'm all about Siege
except for I didn't yeah I'm pretty much the
sky's got a lump under foot soldiers this
time that's a pretty good lineup
imma keep it I'll keep that
certanium footsoldier I'm telling you this
is going to be for going to be fine
everybody
did you do
he said for that he's in it for The Inn at
she said for him to be in it
Jimmy that's a real remember
resume yeah
you do I don't know if it's two or three I
don't know I've only played three I'd fight
you I couldn't stand it
I can do the the I just could not get into
the mechanic a mechanic is just just not my
thing
you're really going to play that already did
you really want to win don't you
I mean yeah you're done
you're done if you're going to burn in a car
to try to beat that you're stupid uh oh
seriously I am not spending any more cards
on you
oh that's the hot girl now I don't think
I'll ever
why would you do that it's got to be going
to burn all of his cards of he had to draw
cards did you see that
did you see that he had two spies shit I got
to remember that next round
I should have decoyed I was stupid identical
I'll say my name over this right now
I should be covered
she passed really
I think you just got I think they has a
bunch of other cards
I shouldn't there I just forgot to do, again
I should be for this by yeah
yeah it was done I'm getting kind of sloppy
and I have a decoy enough to do
he just pulled two cards out again a fucking
we might be in trouble I've been playing too
sloppy
I can't play the decoy now God damn it cuz
I'm a lazy ass
I did wrong I did it wrong
so I know there's a lot you know what you
didn't see my last three games I'm playing
this game really quickly
so there I'd still think I I think I won
please have a weather card please have a
weather card please I have a weather card
it's only got right here
I don't think he has 22in I don't think he
does I'm going to say he doesn't
I don't think he has 22 in him I got 100 I
lucked out
and that eventually lost
I put that fast I didn't pay attention I
miss play my my dick I didn't Paid It All
actually.
Once ranked Siege once ranked sees you the
beating I didn't need to
I didn't need to swap I think I needed to
that we could we could have did we could do
the we could do that he's got a lot of spies
I want to try something with the spies
I want to try something with you spies I'm
going to try to steal one of the spies
I think I can write I think I can still want
to despise of a plant
also didn't play tarantula decoy
what kind of kind of what kind of spread out
that's not bad
I'm kind of spread out he's kind of a dick
when you can replace him
as much better all right I'll see you then
when one car per person yeah I know I know
I actually want to try something I needed
more money to so he just play this little
guy was she the same
I see how far it goes
if he's going to push this. I think he's an
idiot
dad at at at at at at at at at at the
Georgia
Anchors Aweigh spit why did I get any cards
what happened why did I get any cars from
her I supposed to get a card from her
oh I did have any discard I told him this
play that.
I try to recover
and play something stupid you passed you
passed on 22 seriously
you're seriously going to pass on 22 God
damn it I mean it's an easy win
easy win so I can't stress it up there
tkl keyboard if you have a preference
I don't know we talked about I don't give a
shit about keyboards
I used the best keyboard used by writers and
authors not gamers
I want to play early so I can get her decoy
back
I may have to buy a new car immediately
right
yeah that's to her
Chucky's why I don't want travel on my keys
I want low-profile keyboard scientifically
proven to be better keep or better offer for
help better for type better for Speed
I guess
ticket to to to to to to to
are you just sending I don't know if any of
that yet
I mean if I need to
I want to go to High I don't want to go too
high here we go
66% size yeah I just in pain all the time
I sent that all the time here I really am
not a fan of that stuff
yeah I've seen a lot of them it's kind of
trendy it's like a Zoomer thing
there's no reason for it just if you like it
you like it fine that's fine but just people
who like
history of the gates album
crazy ass so you know cyberpunk keyboards or
understand funky words that are completely
useless but they like them you know and
that's fine that's what they like
12 to 12 who wins when there's a when
there's a tie so I want to know
who wins when there's a tie I just want to
find out
no because you can supply card hasn't passed
yet so
this is tricky on bike
there is actually a rule about this where
one always if there's a tie to automatically
win I think it's a monsters
I really feel like it's dangerous to go
another round but if I knock him out on this
when I win the whole game so
going to go ahead and do it
right side real real estate
I stretch my shoulders recharge Mouse
yeah. That's that's a legit that's a legit
thing
yeah that's I think I could try to jail
based on that I hear what you're saying
I hear what you're saying yep
I see what you did yeah that is that is
probably one of my biggest annoyances is
that I have to go so far I still use my
number I had for so much though you know
what I mean I really do I use my new phone
for a lot of things a nerd and numbers a lot
so I don't I don't but I do know what that
makes sense if only had to get do was go
over here that would that would reduce my
shoulder strain a lot
I think about that DiCaprio no that's a good
that's a good idea that's a good point
yep Mac does make one that's just that's
just like the Strait of keys I do use the
arrow keys on occasion
there's no applications that make more sense
20 keys sometimes I use page epenesa
but yeah that does make sense
I like I would probably really love a 60%
keyboard my fingers are not long enough to
do really intense I've noticed it on the
laptop that has 60% or 70% like that imma
let imma let imma let better
yeah I'm a lot faster I have noticed that
certain so that that might be something I
would consider
hey I got coal I just go kill something and
then I'll go to bed
find the pillar set a roach or a girl
stretch
wait where's Roach any toll roads account
number
I can't do that yeah yeah I like to hear
your keyboard on his eye yeah
Rush where are you dude you make me run the
whole way
you aren't you I don't like fastrax there's
a lot of people use special said you not
like them
they're your buddy all right let's go
yeah I think you're right I think is my
right shoulder does sometimes have trouble
so that makes a lot of sense actually
my heart's time should be going down I'm on
the Strode
I don't understand it should be taking a
horse out of town because we're on the road
what's up what's up lady
sure
oh my God
true
I got 10 whole experience points
defender of the faith Suite rack that I
guess we're track
fix all the shrines what the fuck
all right I am going to fix all the shrines
for these two crazy ass people
but how can we how can we gather all the
flowers you say if we're not
the hugest second one of the shrines yes
that's true
I'm gathering flowers
I love this game I just walking around in
this game I got to tell you it is like so
much fun
it's so relaxing and just like get your
dopamine going
I know it's got such great music it's just a
great thing to relax to
oh hey so I can punch out the wolves
a Bandits
shit he's got an ax access or pain in the
ass
oh God I need to get out of here come on how
come it's not feeding
all right all right I fine I'm going to I
won't fuck around shit
driving road trip
I draped on oil on accident so I almost died
I tricked my oil weight I need I need I need
a guard card
are you hard can I can't remember how to do
it
artist
choo choo choo I can't remember how to do my
service are
I turn rest of you off cuz I didn't want to
cheat in case you're wondering treat recipe
off is like resumes totally cheating
I think I think recipe silly cheating is
there music is Toledo yes
I was expecting I could have done to punch
out fight a fight and had my keys right
I forgot how to do I've got to do on my
special things
how do you do the stuff it's funny cuz I had
my fingers know it and I just can't remember
it
undertale now no I know of it though
how do you do
so it's cute yeah this is so funny I could
not remember but my fingers can remember it
hey rain is going to rain is too tight it
looks like rain
are in the swamp is Mike wax when
all right are we going do we seriously have
to cross the water I don't want to cross the
border and I don't want to swim
cuz that's how I am I'm going to walk I'm
going to Longway flowers
flowers
it's dangerous in these Woods you don't know
what I think it is
where that means is a wolf around I M A Wolf
Run somewhere over bear
wait that's not on the map I only got here
ho ho hey we found her we found your first
sex interest
no you do not
I can't believe I happened on her on
accident
she's she's on the main girls from Witcher 3
I probably will blue balling except for Tris
I know C
I don't really go that way we could either I
don't know do we play good I've already done
all that shit I've done the horse in the
stuff
so I don't need to do it but if you all want
to see it I understand completely
it's like
this the sex with her is kind of like kind
of pisses you off later at the end because
you realize she's using you the whole time
that's why I don't want have sex with
anybody was using me
wait what black eyeliner the fuck
black lion are in a pinch when it fried from
Professor fried ice cream mix by the iron I
guess that's how Siri got her black eyeliner
apparently
they had to put that in there is like how
the fuck does Siri gets this for a Black
Island
can't believe we fucked girl I know exactly
I know it'sand it's kind of bad cuz I know
it's had already so I'm not into her at all
asset matters matters to me anyway
no neutral ever go
I think this might mess up the order of
interesting cuz I I found it out of order oh
shit we can still all the stuff
yeah but we got that one and then I'm going
to still I can I jump up and get that shit
I think I can I guess not did I pass it
wear something else engine River oh right
here we go
well it doesn't look good
you think I was very astute Arrow girl.
Shit do we chase her or not
letter to Alexander
darling I'm writing you because she must be
worried that I'm still angry silly man you
know full well that I never hold a grudge
for long I forgive you this so you know
she's full of shit it's a very secretive
secretiveness of yours is so strange for me
to be taken if you seen your plague research
at door watching you work in your Tower
please if you still refuse to discuss the
results of your experiments with me at least
don't deny me this small pleasure I if Sarah
doesn't need just need you tomorrow evening
come see me will clear everything up over a
glass of wine or two or more your k
manipulating vetch she is she is the worst
kind
I don't want to go in the portal on an ounce
I don't like for those I'm garold Carol
doesn't like portals
what's on your anything else or just at the
steel all right we're going to steal
everything
Timber
new Alchemy format Albedo oh that's you
what does albuterol do cobwebs are gross all
right when we got
use use where's it go are we already do that
okay
wait I forget something
just getting ready to get that can damn it I
think I need to make Albedo
I think I need to make Albedo should we do
it this week wrapped it
I'll be there where is it
Alchemy ingredients missing
so
magic item what does it do I'll be do
chemical use the Alchemy o
blue View Vision how do I not have a blue M
University what I've been waiting all this
time
Festiva tell me what is a blue moon as you
give Shadwell at Ennis
awesome inside intensity 1/2 % Ocean City
so the sense that I could probably make that
I don't know if I need them
where's my ground we have
city of its Vitality I think eyetality
sign intensitysign intensity I mean I do
like the sign stuff but all right here we go
into the portal
oh and that magic place I remember
it's the killer bunny or is it
my sis loot
Advanced ages many think I am sovereign
receive any real life I have not it's pretty
good though we need to Stage is simply an
elder speech term for sorcerer
if you could have sex with the common
practice of magic is akin to considering a
newly drafted private
he's sticking out of his breeches at which
was equal of simply because both wield
swords as Sage wields magic true and us with
greater skill and even the most accomplished
then even mostly composed of human ages the
great Renown and Regard in which they are
held however
comes not from the scale by from the other
rather true abilities they possess nothing
is secret from the oven stage they see both
past future and usually is present they have
Mastery over the Arcana of magic as well as
every Tomatoes scholarship they are the only
ones who understand the nature of operation
the so-called Elder blood and the genre of
Laura Dern and the gene of Laura Dern and
they guard the snow was yours actually
understand Elder blood and Laura door in a
lot better from the movie from the from the
Netflix than ever before how do you rinse
all the Elven stages and all my life have
won that one either and Men of the Blue
Mountains she might possess and be the last
episode of them series cast it is true I
have encountered method a male elf who might
also belong to it but as of this writing I
have been able to confirm this
so this is her saying this
I'm upstairs don't be shy
I'm upstairs naked don't be shy or just
going to give me a kiss going to give me in
trouble with twitch for showing digital
boobies
can I show digital movies on Twitch I'm
going to get yelled at
it's a naked woman in Witcher I told you
digital boobies
am I going to get in trouble do they report
you for digital boobies
turn around my naked body do you have a
birthmark girl
it's funny cuz there's boobies on my 60 inch
television cuz my wife was withdrawing today
in the front room there's like a naked women
everywhere
as you got clothes on now
yep
hatches an asshole
looking for a certain way of woman
high performance
hey how are you
you can't do that
a prayer that you could probably put us
thinking between in
hey look the rabbits are humping
and me too hard I mean I wouldn't do it if
you try it though
AR points this is a big Quest right here
I slap you time for me to go to bed this is
a this is a big Quest I remember we were
going to go in the dungeon and fight a ton
of shit
and find the Elven everything so we're going
to go ahead and save this
I call it a night I will be back tomorrow
morning at 11 and
well yeah I mean you can write an
application with you have to figure out the
encryption algorithm is everything
so they can join me for a download I mean
for Witcher
I'm going to call it a night tonight and see
really anybody else to raid must try
there's somebody else in
in in in in which Earl and actually browse
Witcher
before let's do that let's browse The
Witcher category
I am not done that let's do that
games of Witcher
adventure action, cats are they real Witcher
Witcher 3 the wild Hunt
show me my camera right now right I should
be my Cattery
who else is there to read Tulsa coin to your
Witcher I mean
the red car since she seems nice
how much is a partner I guess all right fine
read
Hatsan I've never met this person so
star-trade
pretty sure I'd see you all later